dans cette guerre vladimir poutine peut
compter sur le soutien logistique de la
tchétchénie son dirigeant ramzan kadirov
a annoncé avoir envoyé des combattants
tchétchènes en ukraine pour aider les
soldats russes on en parle avec vous
wassim nassr bonjour vous êtes notre
spécialiste du mouvement djihadiste qui
sont ces hommes et où sont-ils est-ce
qu'on a des informations sur leur
présence en ukraine on ne peut avoir
beaucoup d'informations parce qu'ils ont
eux-mêmes diffusé des images de leurs de
leur déploiement on sait qu'ils sont
présents au nord dans la zone
d'exclusion autour du réacteur nucléaire
de tchernobyl ils ont ils sont aux
combats dans cette zone là et aussi au
nord de la crimée ils ont passé à
l'incursion des forces des forces armées
russes et aussi on a des images on a des
images de ça après il faut rappeler
quand même que la tchétchénie fait
partie de la fédération de russie donc
les combattants tchétchènes participent
à l'effort de guerre finalement dans
leur propre pays ils sont pas à leur
premier coup ils ont déjà participé à
pas mal d'opérations militaires russes
dernièrement par exemple en série sous
la forme de police militaire là on voit
les images sur le front qui a été percée
par les russes au nord de la crimée donc
c'est un combattant tchétchènes qui va
enlever un drapeau ukrainien et mettre
le drapeau des forces des forces
tchétchènes mais la présence la plus
grave la plus importante en tout cas
prouvé à jusqu'à l'heure on a aussi des
images des à des convois militaires
c'est dans cette forêt autour du
réacteur de tchernobyl
et là on voit on voit les images donc
c'est un convoi assez assez important on
les voit prier dans la
dans la forêt et puis exhibé eux mêmes
leur présence là bas il ya un autre
convoi qui a été frappé dans une autre
localité à l'ouest de kiev ça ne serait
pas celui là donc ce qu'on voit là on
sait pas ce qu'il est devenu en gros
mais il faut insister sur quelque chose
ce sont des combattants certes radicaux
certes responsable d'exactions en
tchétchénie avant que ça soit sur les
opérations ou les théâtres de combat aux
côtés de l'armée russe ne sont pas des
jihadistes d'ailleurs dans le sens al
qaïda ou état islamique parce que les
djihadistes eux mêmes réseaux d'al qaîda
au delà est eric les considèrent comme
des apostats et se bat contre eux
reçoivent en tchétchénie au daguestan
dans le caucase ou dans le caucase en
général donc c'est quelque chose
d'important même kadirov en ralliant ses
troupes a annoncé qu'il devra des primes
en argent pour chaque militaire et
craignent un tuyau pour chaque tank
détruits et c'est donc leurs motivations
ne sont pas jihadistes et on voit
d'ailleurs l'insigne de saint georges
sur eux et on sait que leurs motivations
sont plutôt ces décès les hommes de main
on va dire de kadirov qui lui même est
un seigneur de guerre pratique qui
pratiquent un islam plus tôt soufi
inféodés à vladimir poutine et encore
une fois ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'il colle qui pâtit pas des occasions
de la russie c'est vraiment la dernière
fois ils ont eu cette expérience
plusieurs fois avant ajustements à ce
que leur présence peut changer le cours
de cette guerre en ukraine déjà il faut
voir par exemple que kadirov a vraiment
mis en scène à grozny ont là aussi les
images les images de cela là on est
encore dans les images du convoi au nord
de honor 2 a peut-être charleville et là
c'est le grand raout café café kadirov à
grozny on voit en fait des milliers de
combattants sur fond d'un hymne du nîmes
dan djihadistes qui a été modifié avec
de la musique à la gloire de son père
etc mais avec vraiment une connotation
religieuse pour justifier ce combat mais
cette teinte on va des religieuses n'a
rien à voir avec les motivations réelles
de ces de ses combattants et encore une
fois qu'ils sont pas là premier coup
donc on voit ce que cette mobilisation
qui vient après l'envoi des de ses
forces spéciales on va dire en
biélorussie parce qu'ils ont créée elle
a passé depuis la biélorussie donc après
cet effet de propagande on va dire
c'est trop plat ont toujours été
supplétifs des forces russes elles n'ont
jamais eu un rôle décisif sur d'autres
terres mais on peut on peut imaginer
qu'ils peuvent avoir un rôle d'impact
psychologique sur les ukrainiens
connaissant les exactions dont ils sont
responsables déjà chez eux sur d'autres
théâtres elle a la réputation kiso de
faire réciter au combat et
d'aguerrissement au combat etc etc mais
l'apport militaires sur le terrain en
tout cas pour le moment on l'a pas vu et
on ne sait pas si au delà de ce qui est
montré aujourd'hui ils vont avoir un
rôle décisif dans des opérations
militaires proprement parlant on a eu
des infos comme quoi il y en a qui ont
été arrêtés à kiev en essayant de faire
des opérations de sabotage mais pas des
opérations militaires sachant que
aujourd'hui l'opération militaire en
tout on va dire elle va très lentement
par rapport à ce qu aurait voulu le
président russe donc l'écroulement de
l'état ukrainien mais on est quand même
dans les normes militairement parlant en
termes d'avancement sur le terrain merci
beaucoup à tignes pour